This election, your choice couldn't be more
important.
Our candidate is in flattering lighting and
full bright color
Their candidate is in grainy, high-contrast
black and white, spotted through a telephoto
lens from behind a bush coming back from God-only-knows where.
Our guy points at the horizon and
holds a baby.
Their guy doesn't have a baby.
Their guy has a golf club.
The voice over for our guy is calm, measured,
bright.
Their guy gets the lower register, and sometimes,
we
slow
down.
Our guy has clean headlines and the beautiful
lens flare America needs.
Here's a scary graph over a photo of the other
candidate awkwardly laughing.
Snap zoom.
Do you want a snap zoom like that in office?
Here’s a photo of our guy saluting military
veterans.
Jump cuts. Flashes. Static. Aggressive colors.
You can't trust a guy with graphics like this.
Our guy gets stock footage of sunrises and
an American flag.
Their guy's flag is upside down, and on fire.
Intercut with overdue bills, war, and a crying
baby.
Our guy gets doctors and astronauts and stimulus
checks.
Flatline. An eagle. Hurricane. The Statue of Liberty. Crime scene tape. Ronald Regan.
Ronald Regan.
A girl running in a wheat field…
...to escape a dangerous sexual predator.
Welding.
Atomic bomb.
This election, the choice is yours.
Their guy.
Or our guy.
Inspiring Slogan.